♪ ♪
>> Brian: HAPPY WEDNESDAY,
EVERYONE.
I AM BRIAN KILMEADE.
AS YOU CAN STAND SITTING IN A
NORMAL CHAIR, NOT ONE OF THE
SMALL ONES CUSTOM CRAFTED TO
FRAME GREG'S ABNORMALLY
CHILDLIKE FRAME.
I AM A FULL-GROWN ADULT.
WE HAVE THE STAGE CREW REMOVE
THIS TO BE CUP BECAUSE I DON'T
SPILL.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS BUT
I AM THRILLED TO BE HERE.
MY WHOLE LIFE I LOVED LATE NIGHT
TV.
REMEMBER WHEN IT WAS GREAT?
STEVE ALLEN, JOHNNY CARSON.
JAY LENO.
THAT'S WHAT WE GREW UP WATCHING.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN I WAS AN INTERN
ACROSS THE STREET AT 30 ROCK, I
INTERVIEWED DAVID LETTERMAN
BEFORE HE HAD HIS BEARD AND WHEN
HE USED IT TO BE FUNNY.
I GIVE HIM A T-SHIRT SO FOR ME
TO BE HERE IN THE NUMBER ONE
LATE-NIGHT SHOW IS TRULY AN
HONOR AND I AM HONORED TO BE
WITH THE PANEL THAT YOU HAVE YET
TO MEET.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT.
DAVID LETTERMAN JUST OPENED UP
TO HIS BIOGRAPHER AND AFFECT"
HIM EXACTLY.
HE SAID THAT WAS INDEED THE
MOMENT, THE ONE HIGHLIGHT OF
CAREER.
I MADE THAT UP.
I COULD BE SUED.
IT'S NO SECRET I COHOST
"FOX & FRIENDS," THE NUMBER ONE
MORNING SHOW AND ALL OF CABLE
NEWS.
BECAUSE OF THAT, I'VE GOT TO
CONFESS, I DON'T REALLY WATCH
THIS SHOW.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW GREG WAS
FULL-TIME AND HAVE A SHOW OF HIS
OWN.
GUTFELD IS ON WHEN I AM FAST
ASLEEP.
I DON'T WAKE UP UNTIL LIKE 230
AND I UNDERSTAND GREG TALKS
ABOUT ME A LOT.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HE
SAYS.
BUT I HAVE A FEW CLIPS THAT WE
CAN WATCH TOGETHER.
>> NEVER LET A CRISIS GO TO
WASTE, A PHRASE COINED BY
KILMEADE'S BARBER.
IT IS IN THE SHAPE OF BELARUS.
KILMEADE'S DOLL COLLECTION.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ME SAD.
IT IS LIKE WHEN KILMEADE ENTERS
A CROWDED ELEVATOR.
THEY TREAT HIM LIKE HE'S GOT
MONKEYPOX.
LIKELY SOMEONE NO ONE CAN STAND.
I CALL THEM CREEPS.
WHY OFFEND BRIAN KILMEADE?
THIS IS GOOD NEWS FOR LAZY,
INCOMPETENT WORKERS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO FORCE
EMPLOYEES TO WEAR PATCHES, JUST
MAKE SURE IT'S FOR A CAUSE THAT
EVERYONE CAN SUPPORT.
>> Brian: THAT WASN'T EXACTLY
WHAT I WAS HOPING FOR.
THAT HURT.
MORE THAN ONE GREG REACHED UP
AND HIT ME IN THE SHINS.
I CAN TAKE IT.
I AM A BIG BOY, LIKE HIM.
IT IS AN HONOR TO BE THE FIRST
NONCAST MEMBER TO GUEST HOST
THIS WEEK.
KAT AND TYRUS WERE UNBELIEVABLE.
I AM TOLD, I AM TOLD I WAS ON
THE TOP OF THE LIST.
WE GOT SOME BEHIND-THE-SCENES
FOOTAGE OF THE SELECTION
PROCESS.
THIS IS KIND OF COOL.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT'S WEDNESDAY AFTERNOON.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE A GUEST HOST
FOR TONIGHT.
>> I THOUGHT BRIAN STELTER
COULDN'T SAY NO.
>> REMEMBER WHAT GREG SAYS,
TREAT THEM WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT.
[LAUGHTER]
I KNOW.
>> I THOUGHT OF SOME OTHER
NAMES.
MARTHA McCALLUM.
SPEAKER DENTIST.
>> BILL HEMMER.
WE NEED TO THINK OUTSIDE THE
BOX.
LIKE CHRIS CUOMO.
NO.
GREG HAS THAT EMERGENCY GUEST
HOST AND BELOW.
I CAN EVER NUMBER WHERE HE KEEPS
IT.
PROBABLY SOMEWHERE NO ONE WOULD
EVER LOOK.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
I KNOW SOMEONE WHO IS DEFINITELY
AVAILABLE.
BRIAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
HOSTING THE SHOW?
YOU ARE OUR FIRST CHOICE.
>> THE ENVELOPE.
>> ANYONE BUT KILMEADE?
>> AT LEAST WE HAVE THE JUDGE
TONIGHT.
>> Brian: GOOD THING I HAD
HIGH SELF-ESTEEM BEFORE THE
SHOW.
TOO LATE, YOU'RE STUCK WITH ME
SO LET'S DO THIS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BIG STORY
OF THE DAY, PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
DESPERATE ATTEMPT TO GET VOTES,
FOR HE GAVE $300 MILLION LOAN
PROGRAM.
IT'S THE CAMPAIGN SCHEME TO GET
DEMOCRATS REELECTED.
ALSO KNOWN AS THE STUDENT LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM.
AS COLLEGES CALL IT, BRIBERY
101.
THE PRESIDENT FOUND TIME TO
ANNOUNCE A HUGE DEAL TO THROW
FEE MONEY -- FREE MONEY AT TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS FOR
HIS SON THREW TENS OF THOUSANDS
AT STRIPPERS.
JUST IN TIME FOR THE MIDTERMS,
THE LIBERAL MEDIA, THEY ARE
EATING IT UP.
LIKE BRIAN STELTER HAVING HIS
LAST MEAL AT THE CNN CAFETERIA.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT IT TOOK AT THE COLLEGE HAS
GOTTEN TOO EXPENSIVE AND
POINTING OUT HE'S KEEPING A KEY
CAMPAIGN PLEDGE.
>> HE TOLD A HEARTRENDING STORY
ABOUT WHY IT'S PERSONALLY SO
IMPORTANT.
HE TALKED ABOUT HOW HIS FATHER
FELT ASHAMED.
>> IT'S ANOTHER VICTORY FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS SUPPORTERS.
AS YOU NOTE, FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AS A WHOLE, TAKE OFF
YOUR POLITICAL HAT ON THAT
FRONT.
EVERYONE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
THEIR LOANS PAID DOWN AND GO TO
COLLEGE.
>> Brian: WE ARE DOOMED.
THE PLAN CALLS FOR A MORE
ONE-TIME MAXIMUM DEBT
FORGIVENESS.
UP TO 20,000 FOR PELL GRANT
RECIPIENTS.
IT WILL COST TO THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER, EVERYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE, $300 BILLION.
IS THERE ANY MATHEMATICIAN IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
EXTENDS THE REPAYMENT POSITIVELY
END OF YEAR SO DON'T WORRY ABOUT
NOT MAKING YOUR PAYMENTS UNTIL
DECEMBER.
WHO IS REALLY GOING TO BENEFIT
FROM BIDEN'S PLAN?
THE
UPPER-CLASS DEMOCRATIC VOTING
BLOC.
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS WHO HAVE
SKILLS WILL GET SHAFTED.
IF YOU PAY YOUR BILLS AND YOU
LIVE WITHIN YOUR MEANS AND PAY
OFF YOUR LOANS, YOU ARE A
SUCKER.
THE PRESIDENT SEES NO PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
IN HIS DELUSIONAL WORLD, IT IS
FAIR.
>> Reporter: IS THIS UNFAIR TO
PEOPLE WHO PAY THEIR
STUDENT LOANS?
>> IS IT FAIR TO PEOPLE WHO
FAMILIES DO NOT OWN MULTIMILLION
DOLLAR BUSINESSES?
IS THAT FAIR?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Brian: DOES THAT MAKE ANY
SENSE TO ANYBODY?
THE PRESIDENT GETTING A LITTLE
FEISTY.
HE'S ALWAYS ANGRY.
I'M NOT SURE WHY.
THE CATO INSTITUTE, MY FAVORITE
INSTITUTE SAYS THERE'S SEVERAL
REASONS FEDERAL STUDENT DEBT
CANCELLATION IS A BAD IDEA.
FIRST IT HELPS THE WINNERS,
THOSE WHO MADE THE DECISION TO
GO OUTRAGEOUSLY TO GO OUT TO
OUTRAGEOUSLY OVERPRICED COLLEGES
AND GET A DEGREE.
THE HIGHER THE DEGREE THEY
EARNED, THE MORE MONEY THEY WILL
MAKE.
IT SUPPOSED TO PAY OFF THEIR
DEBTS.
WOULDN'T YOU THINK THAT?
IT'S NOT LIKE THOSE DOCTORS WILL
GIVE YOU A REBATE WHEN YOUR
COLONOSCOPY PAYS FOR THEIR
MERCEDES?
IT'S ALSO REGRESSIVE.
MORE OF THE AID WOULD GO TO THE
HIGHEST EARNERS.
GIVING MONEY BACK TO THOSE WHO
NEEDED THE LEAST.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
NOT TO MENTION THE HUGE COST TO
TAXPAYERS AND THAT'S MORE
RECKLESS THAN PAUL PELOSI
ENTERING THE INDY 500.
THANK YOU, JESSE WATTERS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DECIDES LATER TO
CANCEL THE 50 GRANT IT WOULD
COST TAXPAYERS $1 TRILLION.
FORGIVING THE ENTIRE AMOUNT,
$1.6 TRILLION.
THE STUDENT LOAN HANDOUTS WOULD
INCENTIVIZE GREATER INFLATION
SINCE NEITHER UNIVERSITIES OR
FUTURE STUDENTS WILL BELIEVE
FUTURE LOANS WILL HAVE TO BE
REPAID LIKE TODAY'S FRESHMAN.
AND THEY CALL THE LEGALITY OF
THE BIDEN DECISION NOTING THAT
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES CONGRESS,
NOT THE PRESIDENT, THE POWER OF
THE PURSE WHICH IS OFFICIALLY
THREATENING GIVEN THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T HAVE POWER OVER HIS OWN
FOR THE MOST PART.
AS USUAL, THE RIGHT WING
EXTREMISTS ARE PUTTING DOWN THE
PRESIDENT.
>> PEOPLE THINK THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES HAS THE POWER
FOR DEBT FORGIVENESS.
HE DOES NOT.
HE CAN POSTPONE.
HE CAN DELAY.
BUT HE DOES NOT HAVE THAT POWER.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T DO IT, SO
THAT'S NOT EVEN AS A DISCUSSION.
>> Brian: YEAH, WHEN YOU LOSE
NANCY PELOSI, YOU LIVE LOSE
EVERYBODY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE REAL
PROBLEM, COLLEGE COSTS.
THE RATE OF INFLATION OVER THE
PAST CENTURY AND THE COSTS KEEP
GOING UP.
IT'S NOT LIKE GRADUATES ARE
GETTING SMARTER.
IF THEY WERE, THEY WOULDN'T
COMPLAIN ABOUT PRONOUNS, AS SOME
-- AM I CORRECT?
THEY WOULD COMPLAIN ABOUT
INTEREST RATES PERHAPS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CHART.
LOTS OF NUMBERS, LOTS OF BARS,
ALL GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, NO BETTER.
ALSO COST AN ARM AND A LEG.
YOU CAN'T ARGUE WITH CHARTS.
PUT TOGETHER BY MATHEMATICIANS,
STATISTICIANS, AND
AESTHETICIANS.
WAIT, I GOT CONFUSED.
I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE GOOD
PEOPLE WHO PUT TOGETHER
NANCY PELOSI'S FACE EVERY DAY.
THE POINT IS COLLEGE COSTS ARE A
LOT OF MONEY.
THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE HUNDREDS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BUT NOT
WHEN YOU'RE A COLLEGE INFLATING
COSTS, KNOWING HE GOES PAST THE
TAXPAYERS.
BIDEN HAS MADE GOOD ON HIS
PROMISE TO PARTIALLY WIPE OUT
STUDENT LOAN DEBT BUT NOT
EVERYBODY'S HAPPY.
YOU KNEW IT WAS A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE IT WOULD TURN INTO A RACE
ISSUE.
WOKE EDUCATOR NINA TURNER
TWEETING "CANCELING 10,000 IN
STUDENT AT THE AVERAGE WHITE
BORROWER HAS 12,000 IN DEBT
WHILE BLACK WOMEN HOLD OVER
52,000 IN DEBT IS JUST
UNACCEPTABLE.
IT IS STRUCTURAL RACISM."
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER WHEN
BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS PASSED
THE INFLATION ACT, THE ROUTE
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAID
IT WOULD BE VOTE BUYING AT ITS
MOST RAW.
IT SUMS IT UP.
THAT'S SLIGHTLY LESS ANNOYING
THAN CARS FOR KIDS.
♪ ♪
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
IT'S GOING TO BE IN YOUR HEAD
THE REST OF THE DAY.
IT SEEMS UNETHICAL.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES?
YOU ARE LOW ON CASH, YOU CAN
ALWAYS JOIN THE GAS COMPANY
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
TELL THEM THAT THE BIG GUY SENT
YOU.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
SHE'S THE ONLY JUDGE WHO OWNS
HER OWN -- DOES HER OWN
EXECUTIONS.
COHOST OF "THE FIVE,"
JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO.
HE'S OUR FAVORITE CHARLIE AFTER
BROWN AND HORSE.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
CHARLIE HURT IS WITH US.
IT AIN'T LAUNDRY DAY, SO SHE
CAN'T PRETEND.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT MEANT.
IT MADE A LOT OF SENSE IN
REHEARSAL.
HE GRABS BULLS BY THE HORNS AND
GREG BY HIS UNDERWEAR.
N.W.A. WORLD TELEVISION
CHAMPION, TYRUS.
THAT'S OUR SHOW.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
THAT WAS THE LONGEST OPEN I'VE
EVER HAD.
THAT IS LIKE FIVE
"FOX & FRIENDS."
>> Kat: 11 STORIES IN THAT
TIME.
>> Brian: I'M GOING TO SPEND
THE WHOLE SHOW MAKING UP FOR
YOUR INTRODUCTION.
TYRUS, HIS LOAN FORGIVENESS
RACISM?
>> Tyrus: I LIKE YOU ALREADY.
GREG NEVER PICKS ME FIRST.
KILMEADE IS ALL RIGHT.
>> Brian: I ALSO LIKED YOUR
BOOK.
>> Tyrus: YOU DID.
YOU READ IT.
THE GREAT ENABLER IN CHIEF.
THIS IS WHAT HE DOES.
HE'S A BAD PARENT, AS WE TALKED
ABOUT WITH HUNTER AND IT'S THE
SAME POLICIES WITH HOW HE
GOVERNS.
HE THROWS MONEY AT THINGS.
IN THIS CASE, IT'S A BOOMERANG.
IT'S LIKE A REBATE FOR
DONATIONS.
THE PEOPLE THAT SUPPORTED HIM
ARE GOING TO GET A NICE CHECK
FOR THEIR SPOILED BRATS STILL
LIVING AT HOME.
BECAUSE THERE FOR THEIR FERRARI
NEEDS NEW STUFF.
THIS GOES BACK, IT'S SO
FRUSTRATING.
THIS IS THE BEST THING FOR THE
AMERICAN WORKING CLASS PEOPLE
WHEN THEY GO TO THE BALLOT BOX.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE LIKE WOW,
HE'S NOT FOR US AT ALL.
THESE IT'S ABOUT THE ELITE.
FIRST WORLD PROBLEMS.
I COULDN'T PAY MY LOAN WHEN I
GOT OUT OF COLLEGE I HAD A PELL
GRANT SO I DIDN'T PAY IT FOR TEN
YEARS.
I WORKED.
I ANSWER THE PHONE.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
I WAS ON THE LEON.
I RAN AND I BUILT MYSELF UP AND
GOT MYSELF TOGETHER AND
EVENTUALLY THEY CALLED AND SAID
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A PAYMENT
TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF US WERE
FORCED TO DO.
THE ONES WHO JUST PAID IT OR
WORSE, THE MOMS AND DADS WHO
DIDN'T GO ON VACATIONS, DIDN'T
BUY THE NEW CAR, DIDN'T HAVE
AMAZING CHRISTMASES, THAT PUT
MONEY AWAY AND SACRIFICED SO
THEY COULD PUT THEIR KIDS
THROUGH COLLEGE.
WHAT ARE YOU TELLING THEM?
>> Brian: I DON'T KNOW IF THE
OTHER PANELISTS CAN MATCH THAT
ANALYSIS.
DO YOU WANT TO TRY OUR CALL IT A
DAY?
HERE'S WHAT JASON FUHRMAN SAID,
TREASURY ADVISOR TO OBAMA AS
WELL AS BIDEN.
"POURING ROUGHLY HALF A TRILLION
DOLLARS OF GASOLINE INTO THE
INFLATIONARY FIRE ALREADY
BURNING IS RECKLESS.
DOING IT WHILE GOING BEYOND FOR
A CAMPAIGN PROMISE OF $10,000
AND BREAKING ANOTHER PROPOSAL
THAT'S PAID FOR IS EVEN WORSE."
HIS OWN SIDE IS COMPLAINING
ABOUT THIS.
>> Kat: YEP.
OBVIOUSLY.
I'M SOOTHING TO THINK BIDEN JUST
LOVES INFLATION.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHAT OTHER EXPLANATION IS THERE?
I GET SICK OF CALLING IT
FORGIVENESS OR CANCELLATION
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THAT.
IT'S JUST STEALING FROM OTHER
PEOPLE IS ALL IT IS.
[APPLAUSE]
I ALSO PAID OFF MY
STUDENT LOANS.
I ALSO STRUGGLED FOR YEARS AFTER
COLLEGE.
WHAT PEOPLE SAY OFTEN AS THEY
SAY OKAY, JUST BECAUSE YOU
SUFFERED, DO YOU WANT OTHER
PEOPLE TO SUFFER?
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
ACTUALLY BY DOING THIS, YOU'RE
MAKING PEOPLE IN THE FUTURE
SUFFER TOO BECAUSE THE PRICE OF
COLLEGE IS GOING TO GO UP EVEN
FURTHER.
THAT'S HOW IT ALL STARTED THAT
IT GOT SO EXPENSIVE.
>> Brian: CHARLIE, THE WHAT IF
YOU ARE 38, WHAT IF YOU'RE 45?
HUGO WAIT A SECOND.
I'M AN IDIOT FOR MAKING MY
PAYMENTS AND IF I'M A FRESHMAN,
WHY DO I THINK I'M GOING HAVE TO
PAY THAT LOAN BACK.
>> Charlie:IST FUNDAMENTALLY
UNFAIR.
THAT'S WHAT STICKS IN THE CROSS
SO MANY PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WILL WORK SO HARD TO DO
THAT.
LET'S NOT FORGET WHAT THIS IS.
IT'S A BAILOUT OF COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES THE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES DON'T NEED.
HARVARD HAS A $31 BILLION
ENDOWMENT.
THEY ARE NOT ALONE.
THAT MIGHT BE THE LARGEST.
THEY ARE ROLLING IN CASH.
KAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE REASON COLLEGE IS SO
EXPENSIVE IS BECAUSE THROUGHOUT
THIS ENTIRE SCAM COLLEGE
TUITION, LOAN SCAM, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN THE BOOKIE
AT EVERY STEP OF THE WAY THEY
GET THEIR CUT.
FOR BIDEN TO DO THIS IS
REWARDING THE SYSTEM.
KAT IS RIGHT.
DO YOU THINK TUITION IS GOING TO
GO DOWN?
NO, TUITION IS GOING TO GO UP.
>> Brian: AND INTEREST RATES
ARE THROUGH THE ROOF.
SOME OF THESE LOANS ARE 10%.
THAT'S ALMOST CRIMINAL.
THAT'S A LOAN SHARK.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU SAY
COLLEGE TUITION IS GOING UP NOT
IN TERMS OF INFLATION BUT THE
SAME WAY THE LOANS ARE GOING UP.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THERE'S THIS
SCAM GOING ON WHERE WE ARE GOING
TO INDOCTRINATE YOUR KIDS.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE YOUR
KIDS BELIEVE IN SOCIALISM.
IT'S MOST LIKE A SOCIALIST
CONTACT BETWEEN THE GOVERNMENT
AND EDUCATION.
THEN WE ARE GOING TO FORGIVE THE
LOAN AND THE END FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE RICH AND DON'T NEED IT.
IF WE HAVE SUCH A GREAT ECONOMY,
WHERE WE GIVING THESE PEOPLE
MONEY?
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY CAN'T GO OUT
AND GET A JOB.
YOU WANT TO GIVE MONEY AWAY,
GIVE MONEY TO THE VETERANS.
GIVE MONEY TO THE SENIOR
CITIZENS WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO GO
OUT AND GET WHAT THEY WANT.
IN THE END, WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
JOE BIDEN KNOWS HE'S UNPOPULAR
WITH KIDS AND YOUNG PEOPLE.
53% OF PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF
35 DISAPPROVAL OF HIM.
HE IS PAYING THEM TO VOTE FOR
HIM.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU GOT TO
CONTRACT, YOU SIGN IT.
YOU AGREE TO PAY IT BACK.
IF YOU DON'T PAY BACK, DON'T
WORRY ABOUT IT.
WE'LL BE AT BACK -- WE'LL PAY
BACK FOR YOU.
>> Brian: YOU HAVE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS AND IF YOU HAVE TO TAKE
A PAUSE, YOU GO TO THE BANK.
YOU GO TO THE BANK AND GO
LISTEN, I NEED A PAUSE.
YOU WAIT 18 MONTHS AND YOU COME
BACK AND YOU'RE PAYING MORE BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY MAJOR
PAYMENTS AND THAT'S IT.
IT'S CALLED SETTING UP A CREDIT
RATING.
WHEN YOU TAKE OUT A LOAN TO GET
A CAR OR SOMETHING, THEN YOU
HAVE A FOUNDATION TO BUILD ON.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS HAPPY.
MOST OF AMERICA ISN'T.
BEFORE WE GO, I'D LOVE TO SEE
YOU ON MY TOUR.
I'M GOING TO BE ON STAGE.
GO TO BrianKilmeade.com.
I WILL BE AT A PLACE CALLED THE
EGG AND ALBANY.
GOING TO TU